robbed this is probably really ignorant
question for someone like me but who is
Ortega not really ignorant because he
really is not a very well-known name
like Warren Buffett three years ago he
could get became the richest person in
Europe so passing Barkham Pradhan back
then nobody really thought about Zahra
even though you've probably shopped
there there's more than six thousand
Zara stores but Amancio Ortega is a guy
who just likes to be left alone in fact
one of his quotes out there and there
very few of them is that I just want to
live a normal life and be able to sip
coffee with my wife and the Piazza with
nobody paying attention to me it's kind
of hard to do when you become the second
richest person yes exactly
how did he get there I mean he is of
course the founder of index but and
that's a big retailer like you said Zara
is under that company but retail has not
been a shor bet by any stretch of the
imagination it has not been in fact the
margins have been shrieking shrinking at
Inditex as well as other retailers since
we started tracking this in 2012 but in
the text is it just has a reputation
it's a really extremely tight operator
they have this fast fashion instant
reply in inventory process where
manufacturing spots are around the world
so when fashion trends change in six
weeks they can restock their entire
stores around the globe but they're
having a really big international
expansion right now so Asia is a really
big part of this story